all right this morning republican
national convention delegates are set to
nominate president trump for a second
term
he plans to appear every night of the
convention in an interview last night
joe biden told abc news why the
democratic nominees are campaigning
from home i understand the restrictions
of covid
and campaigning in this time but can you
win a presidential election
from home we will we're going to follow
the science
what the scientists tell us we've been
able to travel places when we've been
able to do it in a way that we don't
cause the congregation of large numbers
of people
look what happens what's happened with
his his
events people die people get together
they don't wear masks they
end up getting covered they end up dying
so when you hear the president say this
guy's afraid to leave his basement
guess what i have left my basement
and but here on the meantime 500 million
people have watched what i've done out
of my basement
just before the republican convention
the president learned that he is losing
one of his top advisers
paula reed has more from the white house
president trump's longtime aide
kellyanne conway said she would step
down this month to focus on her family
conway was a campaign manager before
transitioning to the white house
where she has been one of the
president's staunchest offenders
this president said more in 47 months
and joe biden did in 47 years
her husband george conway said he will
also step away from his role
with the anti-trump republican group the
lincoln project
their 15-year-old daughter has spoken
out against president trump and
forcefully criticized both her parents
on social media
this weekend she tweeted she was
officially pushing for emancipation
meanwhile the president was dealt
another blow this weekend
this time from his own family change of
stories a lack of preparation the lying
the holy sh
according to audio first obtained by the
washington post
the president's sister retired federal
judge marianne trump ferry
was recorded by her niece mary slamming
her famous brother
all he wants to do is appeal to his base
he has no principles
i'm none none
[Music]
and his base i mean my god if you were a
religious
person you want to help people
the president's chief of staff brushed
it aside you know just another day in
another attack
that we continue to see president trump
is expected to make an appearance on the
first night of the republican national
convention this evening
over the week he will appear alongside
lawmakers and members of his own family
also on this schedule are mark and
patricia mccoskey who went viral
after pointing guns at protesters
outside their st louis home
and alice johnson the former inmate
whose life
sentence was commuted by president trump
at the urging of kim kardashian west
anthony paula thank you our prime time
coverage of the republican national
convention will begin tonight
at 10 p.m eastern 9 central